just give me a list of things you know
i'll walk you will cry
yeah i'm all about on youtube it's have
you seen it
oh my god in fact i want to i want to
play it i cried at the end after this
i cried at the end of black widow what
are you talking about hey why
i liked it i like it i loved black love
that movie no i
i thought that that moment that they
shared the sisters sisters that made me
cry i was like
all that they've been through they have
no uterus you know what i mean like yeah
all this [ __ ] and i was like and she
like admitted that this was my real
family i thought that was touching i
love that but you know what's weird
i want to feel but you know that she's
dead in in the universe
i know but this movie came after civil
war after civil war
that's what made me feel sad about the
whole movie too it's knowing that she's
already she's dead in the
in you know she's suing disney yes big
time suing
big time soon and they're going after
they're trying to they're trying to
trash her in the media and they need to
stop that
because um they released it on the same
day right honestly
and the theater her money is tied to
back end on the thing and so they
they already put it out you know on on
the thing and then she's like yo
yeah we got yeah i got 20 million but
i'm trying to make that dude money
i want that i want uh tony stark money i
want that 68 million money yeah
i want that robert downey money because
that movie let me tell you something
yeah just
real quick yeah what is missing
from a lot of movies that
this wasn't a movie that just happened
to have women in it
interacting with men this was an action
movie
starring women and it's what a lot of
action movies i realize now are missing
because there was an there was something
about that the interactions and
and and and the heart and the with all
that action [ __ ]
that i was like this is fantastic yeah
yeah you know what i mean they nailed it
they nailed it but you know what nailed
it quiet place too
i killed it bro so good so at the end
at the end of quiet place two when the
kids are [ __ ] like having their
moment
and you can see that this is the father
in them yeah
i was like this is just awesome
i loved that part in the movie but it's
not just the that part though
the amazing part the pacing of it
bro it's when to choose to do certain
things oh like oh how about you
i know you mean let's not give away
anything right right what i'm saying
when they go
silence yeah oh what a great device
oh what a great device i can't watch
that kind of movie
so rachel around you know when i was
hungry when i was
in hungary i'm like [ __ ] be quiet it's
the quiet part when i was
when i was in hungary and i ran into him
at the
nobu kazinski john kranziski oh [ __ ]
right and i
made a fool out of myself because i
tried to act too cool
i wish i had seen the movie right
because i want this is what i would say
to him now if i saw him
hey dude it's such a big pleasure to
meet you man and i just i honestly dude
i'm a huge film buff i'm very picky too
very
your movies the quiet players one and
two dude
are just flawless and you're
a legitimate director i would put you up
there with
storyteller storyteller i would put you
up there with jg abrams i would put you
up there with
jordan i mean these guys these performer
actors
now directing [ __ ] my god what
you got to be next do you know what can
i tell you something different time
of different time frame i think he wins
an oscar for the first
quiet place yeah yeah but the world was
different at the time
yeah you know you can't have the you
have the black guy wins for the horror
movie
yeah on the heels of you know oscar's
too white and all this stuff going on
so it's kind of like they go this was
great but we can't give another white
guy
i think he is a victim of that you know
what i mean not to say that the
well didn't deserve john kraske is a
young man still
right he got tired he's got a lot of
time what are they going to continue
that series
oh they have to love how they started
and i loved how he brought himself still
back into it that's genius
i was like good for you like going to
the beginning yeah genius and it's like
the monsters are scary
and and it's just interesting monsters
they're very very detailed
yeah and uh but and emily blunt is just
dude when she's looking at her son for
the first time
when she's looking at her son when at
the end i
saw her thinking oh my god my little
[ __ ] ass boy
is becoming a man no that's the most you
know what i mean
like she had that moment of like he's
gonna do it you know
you know that girl is [ __ ] talented
yeah she has all of it i love her
jessica chastain
is my other favorite i love her like she
though oh she's great those are the ones
man you're
zero dark thirty yeah or or the chick
from uh the chick from uh
be uh i am good or be good or it was
that netflix movie um
uh the one where she was like uh taking
advantage of old people
oh um rogan even talked about it uh i am
good or
i like to be good the girl she's from
the other one uh ratchet
too sarah paulie boom i love sarah paul
those
three like i just i don't care what the
material
is if you're a great actor that can
really delve into like whatever it is
that's why robert downey jr
that's what makes the avengers so great
like an end game when he's all
skinny and he's mad at captain america
that scene right there
i was like that [ __ ] is an actor
man dude he's always been an actor but
don't even [ __ ] fight i know but what
i'm saying is like they've changed the
the the landscape of like you know
thanks to batman begins by the way
uh christopher nolan changed superhero
movies forever with batman begins
yeah because he made it a real movie at
that point all right yeah and ever since
then you get these
like really fantastic actors and
performances so no matter what it is so
now you got like
krazynski with this like horror movie
genre
and they're giving like their all man
that those performances in those two
movies
one and two him her the kids killian
murphy
yeah he was great in it oh my god i know
you want to suck his dick
oh more than that penetration has his
steel anus
yeah but i'm curious though i'm curious
though just just to throw it out like
clyde is at starbucks and this guy he
just comes through and he's like hey you
know
kind of a tiger belly fan i know that
seems weird i heard irish accent
i heard you i heard what you said about
[Laughter]
would you like to suck my dick you know
whatever he would say i mean
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
online therapy check out betterhelp.com
belly for 10 off your first month life
is full of stressors it